for what have you noticed being in front
of these rooms well you know from my
point of view it's a totally different
experience because I'm in Directorate
Gina is a writer so you know I first of
all I haven't had too many opportunities
to pitch a movie you know usually I've
been very very much on the fringes or
very much an independent sigh there's
only a couple of times in my life when I
was able to actually go into the studios
and you know do a pitch but but for a
director it's mostly you're not really
pitting a script you're purchasing a
movie that you want to make you're like
presenting your whole vision how you
visualize it well it is all about oh
yeah of course you have to pitch the
story because if it's a script that you
found or developed or you have to do a
little bit of that too but it's a lot of
it is about just you you know getting
them excited about this imaginary movie
that you want to make and it's a lot of
it is about personality they have to
love you because you got to live with
you for like at least a year or two and
if they start hating you you know
working with a director is a very very
you know very different kind of right
man it's like you're you're working with
with a team with the with the executives
with the finance series of the crew you
know for days and days and weeks and
then maybe in the post-production for
months so you know you gotta like enjoy
being in the room with this person
because I gotta live with this person so
a lot of it is also about personality
you know and about power and about you
know sort of feeling a sense of comic
comradery you know so you know so big
but basically you know you know in most
of the times and I had a chance to pitch
it was after Sundance you know the I've
always in my couple of times in my
career you know twice actually I made a
sort of a hot film at Sundance so for a
brief moment in time you know I got an
opportunity usually like a six months
window to go out and be allowed to speak
and presented you know and in those
times you know a lot of it was like they
wanted to find out who you were and what
what movie they could give you to do but
you always have a whole suitcase of
they've been dreaming to make and
finally won Sundance and it's your
chance to make the movie you've dreamed
of making but they don't very often want
to hear about that they want to hear
about you repeating the same thing that
you just did you know which is a problem
like you know after I did fun I had a
lie I wanted to this huge science
fiction film which had nothing to do
with fun was a total opposite so they
just didn't get it you know they wanted
for me to make more movies about
troubled teenagers which as a business
person you understand yeah yeah but at
the same time you know I got the chance
to read some amazing script that I
wanted to do like Girl Interrupted or
you know Virgin Suicides there was like
some amazing scripts that were given to
me which I just died to direct and I
tried so hard to convince them that was
the guy for the job
but then they gave it to someone else so
you know
you